what is it like going back to probably
one of the most iconic movies again for
me it was very powerful
what's particularly important for me is
that the first movie exists and then
this movie exists in this in the sort of
lore of the Halloween franchise if you
will the the way this movie was
approached was the original movie and
then this movie so there is no there are
no other sequels there are no other
storylines there is just what happened
on Halloween night in Haddonfield and
now what happens on Halloween night 40
years later
are you still in Haddonfield oh yeah oh
no Laurie Strode has never left because
Laurie Strode has believed from the
beginning that Michael Myers is coming
back and it has been her dogmatic belief
that has really ruined her life you know
this is her entire realized - today it's
her entire adult life she was 17 when
this happened so she became an adult
having survived the trauma and now all
of her adult life she has been on the
hunt saying this man is coming back and
she's lost her marriages she lost her
child she's still in Haddonfield waiting
for him so in a sense this is just the
first one in Dallas there's nothing
don't forget all the stuff in between
that's that's the idea the way we took
it Danny McBride and Jeff Radley and
myself we're all film school buddies we
loved the Halloween movies every one of
them when we got the opportunity to
crack into the franchise ourselves and
started looking at the various threads
and mythology that kind of came about
through the series we just kept going
back to the original thinking the
original one is going to be our Bible
we're gonna get it take a take our
lessons from that stylistically and
narrative Lee and then we jump 40 years
acknowledging some of the other elements
of the other films as rumors or things
that people talked about but the truth
is where we are where we go and that's
the game we play oh so it jumps right
there all right what was it like did you
put back on the Laurie Strode
we well originally Laurie Strode didn't
have a way that was Laurie Strode zone
hair and as we know we've followed my Oh
over any period of time my hands got a
little shorter and shorter I'm not sure
it was after that you guys sure pretty
quick yeah I mean ish but what was
important was that we meet a woman who
has not been focused on anything but
Michael Myers for 40 years and so it was
crucial was actually David's call
because if you saw me if Laurie was I
was wearing Laurie Strode is closed you
guys know me pretty well I've been I'm
now at this point I was in that movie I
was introducing me it was my first movie
now of course I've made many movies and
so there is a ubiquity to me there's a
ubiquity to me politically there's a
Bick wa t to me as a spokesperson and a
saleswoman and as an actress and it was
important that when we met Laurie for
the first time that right away you knew
she was Laurie Strode mm-hmm how did the
evolution of killing folks in these
movies how has it moved up to now you
know it's very different in the
beginning you killed folks and it was
kind of like great you just saw blood
fall or they're hanging they do whatever
now it's a little more graphic when they
kill folks is it more graphic or is it
mounted mellow art well a couple things
one is you know we took a lot of our
technical lessons from from carpenters
original film and we really are trying
to play off tension and we let shots go
for a long long period of time and
thinking that that's that's gonna help
us deliver that kind of psychology for
the viewer in it and that really works
at the same time sometimes there's just
a great opportunity to just you know
drive at home and and you can't resist
it so it I'll say we always were playing
with what that balance is and then when
we're in the editing room we just want
to make it delicious really how tough is
Laurie in this movie
well it's a movie about trauma hmm it's
a movie really about what happens to
somebody when you're 17 years old and
you have this horrible trauma
perpetrated on you and you have no help
there are no mental health people that
swoop in and help her and so this is
woman who's carried for 40 years her
entire adult life this trauma and as we
are seeing in the world today all of
these women primarily women who have
been traumatized in all sorts of ways
physical violence emotional violence
sexual violence and in Laura's case
actual you know knife attack violence
all of those women are having the moment
where they will no longer allow that to
be the narrative no longer does that
define them that they are standing up
and saying enough and this is a movie
about enough at a time when it happens
to be a national and worldwide message
and so it couldn't be timed better and
it couldn't have been written better
because you see what other life could
Laurie Strode have she was 17 your
connection to this movie because
remember there was nothing like this
when when Halloween hit yeah and it blew
everybody wait you've had a weird
connection all your life this has been a
big part of your life are you ready to
let this go
can this be the end in a way I like to
look at it and I'm not being morbid as
as we all will every one of us in this
lovely room we will all die one day and
I will tell you that when I die the
headline will be Halloween actress dies
and I couldn't be more proud to think
that something this was a fictional
character written 40 years ago were
written probably longer than 40 years
ago did I have the great privilege of
playing when I was 19 years old and now
40 years later
kissing 60 I am having the opportunity
to play her again so that's the
privilege I'm
[Music]
wildly thrilled do people still put on
hockey masks and try to scare you
it's a roll movie baby right but do
people ever do that what Mike Marra oh
he pulled on the match that was Friday
the 13th wasn't it hockey mask
yes pulled on the mask yeah do people
try to scare me
people try to scare have you been
watching the news people the news it's
scary but I'm talking been watching the
news
I've been watching the news do the words
GOP mean anything to you in the sense of
what is terrifying
it's terrifying out there the world
terrifies me a guy you know in a mask
and eye mask does not the words GOP
terrifies me sorry everybody
by the way did you see Roseanne's
meltdown no where was it it's it's
pretty much everywhere recent oh yeah
just yesterday
oh no no I've been hyping can I show it
to you no okay Roseanne's melt and I
have my own meltdown thank you very much
I know we should all be having a
meltdown thank you very much and if
we're not all having a meltdown there's
a problem let's talk about Halloween
let's talk about Halloween okay about
Halloween have you been back to and will
you go back to head and feel for this
there is no Haddonfield
there is no head and feel this one no
never
no no no there's somewhere near
Haddonfield that you guys use right
isn't that true areas you know what it
is it's a fake say oh what there's a
place near where you isn't it based on a
city and yes Deborah Hill I believe New
Jersey right it was a New Jersey New
Jersey hello
the movie takes place in Illinois and we
are we have returned to Haddonfield
where we find Laurie in a series sum up
some familiar characters we'll little
journey back to Hatton field and then
enjoy our or return to some cinematic
destinies there's a place
Wow I'm gonna as soon as we get out I'm
gonna you can text me I'm gonna text you
the enemy Rosen's meltdown and that I'm
gonna send it to you okay um Michael
Myers finally I mean this is a guy who
hasn't died in my lifetime so is this
finally it we'll see we'll see I never
read it I just showed up I can't wait to
see what happens it's actually I've seen
it yeah are you ready to go over there
is that where I'm going now
yes you're going across you're gonna see
people are shaking their head you're
going over are you going I will go there
at some point apparently do you enjoy
comic-con I enjoy people loving things
I'm a I'm a lover I you know I was
listening to the radio and there's this
new band called Greta Van Fleet I love
them and there's just nothing like
loving something and going like wow and
if that's what people have for this
genre and the movies that I've been in
and movies david has made then that's
why you do it so that people will love
it so in that sense when I joke about
like I have to go over there you know
it's an onslaught like that is not my
life this is not my life you know this
is a promotion for a movie and we will
promote it well I live very quiet
private life so does David but do I love
it I love that people love it people
love this movie they love it and in
response they love me and I am NOT
saying that as a personal there are a
few other movies who did that because
but there's something you know the word
fan you know that fandom that thing that
people love we've all you went to film
school I've worked for 40 plus years
mm-hmm to have to make something that
people love we all want to be loved
everybody wants to have their work
respected I'm sure when people come up
and they say they like your show makes
you feel good so how can it be anything
but that when you give them something as
as David did to make this movie as
terrifying as it is and then be able to
walk into a group of people and go like
for instance our friend who we met today
saw the movie and your first word out of
your mouth was oh my god it's amazing
but you see that's love that's beautiful
to me all right six six thousand people
there saying what the world needs now is
love sweet love
hey one other quick thing are there any
start singing you can see our two little
love sorry are any other are any of the
original characters or anybody else from
the original coming back yes what the
answer is yes but we can't say hope
you'll have to kill me
Lord knows people tried right yeah